well fun fact I was Man Hands on
Seinfeld that's right yeah there's a fun
fact they used one of the crew guys
hands for the insert yes yes
how much popularity did you get for that
well a popularity and more residuals
than I got from HBO like how much have
you made off being on one episode of
Seinfeld as man hands oh my God I wish I
knew that because would you say more
than twenty thousand dollars yeah I'm
guessing off a guest star off a guest
star
of a guest star that paid me probably 3
000 on the day you know shout at you man
well yes and it is really fun the fun
part is once a decade I will randomly
see Jerry Seinfeld at the grocery store
or something right so so Random how are
you well yeah and then I think oh he's
not gonna remember you know a billion
guest stars and then I go he won't know
my name so then I go should I say I
should I and then I usually walk over to
him and go
I am man hands it's so fun
immediately he's so friendly and lovely
how funny is that oh okay
of course I remember you yeah yeah he
does that's amazing you know I'm one of
the few people I haven't seen that
episode but I'm going to I've only seen
probably 10 episodes of Seinfeld yeah I
hadn't seen it either but my brother is
obsessed and most of the world is but I
want to sit down and just watch every
season I started doing that during the
pandemic because I needed to laugh I
watched cheers that I hadn't seen I
watched Seinfeld
so brilliant I mean cheers is brilliant
yeah